yo
let me ask you this with kamikaze being
a classic record right
that was your only album on rockefeller
i didn't actually have an album so that
album wasn't so what was your situation
with them
because you had the chain on you had the
features you you know
that it was it was it was pretty much
more like a family vibe
okay okay okay that we could have took
further but at the time i was on
atlantic records
right i knew the album came out to
atlantic i didn't know if rock so so it
didn't
so you technically never dropped an
album
through rockefeller yeah damn that's
crazy
so that was just some family ties [ __ ]
like hey you're part of the gang here's
the change
you know what i'm saying like definitely
that was far as far as we could take it
we would have took it further if
if the companies could have merged the
situation but
you know unfortunately that couldn't
happen so i had to
live it out keep it moving keep it
moving who was
who were you closest with on the roster
because there was such a a large roster
of artists but you know we're talking
about the young guns we talked about all
the state property beans memphis like
who who was like your your closest
comrade on the rockefeller
roster everybody was cool i had a vibe
with everybody
i probably kicked it the most with with
uh bleak and freeway
freeway's a good dude man those are two
people i probably kicked it with the
most
shouts to free